مع حسن تعرفنا على الاجواء في العاصمه اذا
الارجنتينيه يونس ايرس وكما ذكرت منذ قليل
حسان تنقل الى مكان ومدينه مميزه في
الارجنتين وهي روساريو مسقط راس ليونيل
ميسي حسين اكتشف والكل يكتشف الان الصوره
هذا الشارع نسبيا الضيق من هنا بدات قصه
الاسطوره ميسي ليس كذلك
نحن الان وسط هذا الشارع في حي متواضع
اخرج النجم الذي يعتبر اليوم اسطوره في
الارجنتين ليونيل ميسي سنشاهد هنا هذه
الاجواء التي قام بها سكان الحي الذين
يعرفون ميسي
ان كان يلعب في هذا الحي كان مثلي كثير من
الاطفال الذين ما زالوا يلعبون في هذا
الحي بكره القدم هنا نشاهد هذه الزينه همم
هذه الرسومات التي وضعت حديثا بعد فوز همم
ميسي همم كاس العالم في قطر تم وضع النجمه
التي اضافها ميسي لمنتخب الارجنتين وهنا
تماما سنشاهد الان هذا المنزل منزل النجم
الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي الذي ولد فيه هذا
هو المنزل
كما نشاهد هنا هذا هو منزل النجم
الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي وكما نشاهد هذه
الكلمه الرساله التي وضعها السكان سكان
هذا الحي بكل بساطه على الباب جراسياس
كامبيونس غراسياس ليو وهذا يعني شكرا
للابطال شكرا لك ليو هذه
اللوحه هنا البسيطه كما ترون وضعها همم
السكان شكرا لميسي على احضاره كاس العالم
نشاهد هنا هذا ايضا العلم الارجنتيني مع
رقم 10 لميسي وقد ايضا تم التوقيع عليه من
سكان الحي كله سكان الحي يشكرون ميسي
بالمناسبه همم مارتين اخ ميسي يتواجد هنا
في الداخل وكان قد خرج قبل قليل علينا
وهمم القى السلام لكنه اعتذر عن الظهور
على الشاشه وهو يعيش حتى هذه اللحظه هنا
داخل هذا وحسنت في بدايه الوقت معاذ ان
سمحت لي ان نتعرف على على ان ماريا فقط
لحظات ان ماريا تعيش في هذا الحي من 48
عاما وهي شهدت حتى على ولاده ميسي هي تسكن
في المنزل المقابل وين ستارديس
بريميرو قوموا استاذ سنتيندوز بويسكن ميسي
همم ليفربول
كل احياء الارجنتين يشعرون بالفخر الكبير
ولكنها تستذكر عندما كان ميسي يسير في هذا
الحي يتجول همم يلعب بكره القدم وكانوا
ينظرون اليه يراقبونه ويراقبنا اداءه قالت
انها تشعر بالفخر الكبير لانه استطاع ان
يحقق الحلم بعد سنوات من الانتظار قبل ان
وصلت
[موسيقى]
همم اكثر الذكريات التي تتذكرها عن طفوله
ميسي كانت تقول انه كان طفل مهذب همم لطيف
كان يخرج الى الشارع دائما لكي يلعب كره
القدم كانت تقول له ان ماريا انتبه واحترس
يا ميسي من السيارات التي تمر من هنا
ولكنه وكان يقول لها انني سانتبه واريد ان
نلعب كره القدم عن هذه الذكريات تتحدث ان
ماريا التي رافقت كل اللحظات اخر سؤال
سنساله لان ماريا همم استاذ اسبيراندو كم
ميسي اون ديه همم
كمبيون مونديال كومه اوي
ونوره الورد
[تصفيق]
هي خاتمين
اذا كان سكان الحي وهي شخصيا كانت تتخيل
ان يكون ميسي يوما ما هو نجم وبطل العالم
قالت انها بالفعل عندما كانت تنظر اليه
كانت تتخيل انه سيكون نجم كبير وسيكون له
شان كبير واليوم هم يشعرون بهذا الشعور
بهذا الفقر بعد ما تحقق الحلم بالنسبه لهم
وهمم استطاع احد سكان هذا الحي ان همم
يقوم بالفعل برفع كاس العالم ان يشاهد هنا
هذه التفاصيل المنزل الذي تم تزيينه بعد
لحظات فقط من فوز ميسي والمنتخب
الارجنتيني بكاس العالم سنشاهد ايضا هذه
اللوحه التي وضعت هنا في هذا المكان معز
ان سمحت لي وهي صوره لميسي ينظر الى
السماء وكتب بالقرب منها في
اا الملعب في مكان الاعلانات في الملعب
جراسياس اي شكرا لك ميسي الجميع هنا يشكره
الاستاذ هؤلاء الاطفال هنا ايضا وهم
يرفعون الكره هنا ال- ال- لها طعم اخر حتى
انا عندما لعبت بالكره للامانه شعرت بشعور
مختلف في هذا الشارع
ميسي مسقط راسه روساريو تحديدا ايضا هذا
المكان هذا البيت لكن ميسي غادر همم
روساريو تقريبا في السنه الثالثه عشر وذهب
الى برشلونه ولكل يعرف قصته في اسبانيا مع
برشلونه كنت اريد ان اسال همم هذه المراه
تحديدا عن همم هل تنتظر وتتوقع ان يعود
ميسي همم من حيث بدا هنا ليلقي التحيه
ليحتفل الى ربما همم مع همم سكان هذا الحي
تحديدا بهذا الانجاز وهل كانت له ايضا في
مناسبات سابقه عوده الى هذا لانه نعلم
جيدا ايضا هو في روساريو الان متواجد ميسي
ولكن في مكان اخر في بيت بطبع افضل بكثير
وفخم والكل يعلم باقي التفاصيل ربما
نعم بالفعل معز همم نحن كنا قد سالنا عن
ذلك نحنا بالمناسبه منذ الصباح الباكر في
هذه المنطقه نقوم باعداد تقرير خاص عن
مدينه روزاري وعن سانتافي عن هذه الولايه
التي نشا فيها ميسي وكنا قد سالنا عن ذلك
وقالوا لنا انهم ينتظرون عوده ميسي الى
هذا المكان في اي لحظه يتمنون ان يكون ذلك
يوم غد وهم كانوا يتحدثون عن ذلك وايضا
فيما يتعلق بعودته الى هذا الحي هو بدايه
هذا المنزل كما ذكرنا قبل قليل ما زال
منزل للعائله ما زال اخو همم ميسي يعيش
داخل هذا المنزل بالفعل ولكن في ذات الوقت
فانه كان ياتي كما قالوا لنا الى هذا
المنزل همم الذي سنراه هنا همم هذا المنزل
الذي يوجد هناك باللون الاحمر همم
الكاسه الرمال
هذا المنزل معز هو المنزل الذي كان ياتي
اليه في الاعياد في المناسبات
ويقوم بزياره الاهالي بشكل خاص ويحضره
صديقه صديق طفوله من هنا دينجو
اخر
من روساريو ديماريا والعديد العديد من
الاسماء بينهم حتى اسكالوني مدرب المنتخب
على كل حال شكرا جزيلا لك حسين مسعود شكرا
على كل جهودك وانت معنا اذا من حيث
ميسي وافسح لك المجال تلعب كره القدم في
هذا الشارع مميز ربما اكتشف حسان مسعود
لاعب كره قدم شكرا لك